yeah that was a great episode that we
learned about signs so my I did we learn
about Pratt pass things
did we not George would you think of it
I was thoroughly entertained by my arm
by our own voices
you said I'm very proud of you
what do we do do we not do it together I
feel like you carried most babe I think
that's the groove back we did it I think
you're getting your groove back I do I
do
before we go what whitaker or oh okay
what your final pick or if you don't
have to choose anyone but your thoughts
thoughts Whitaker is the my most
favorite fighter and all of UFC has been
for the past year really Avery I love
him I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm Maggie he's
the only fighter I follow on Instagram I
love him sorry DC so I gotta let me ask
I got a new phone okay and I have the
email thing you know how it says the
email of the amount of emails what's a
lot to mine which is five thousand oh oh
that's a lot I thought your says mine
says 17,000 what does that mean I
thought I had a lot so there's ten great
worth of emails that I haven't even
opened Jesus you know what you should do
what we should go dig deep into song
should look at what what you used to say
to ex-girlfriends that's what something
I never emailed anybody that's yes I'm
sure you did oh you think I have let me
good wait so kyla you want Whittaker out
of Sonya I think I'll always when I'm
with Whitaker I'm with Whitaker with the
kalila on that one
I love him I decide I'll just say it's
great go ahead I love you I to Sonya and
then what do you want either the
nickname who else is fighting that night
tomorrow a Saturday and let's look up
she be good karna
we have mm-hmm all right so like in - oh
it's Luther King Day Kunta Kinte like
Kunta Kinte and Dan hooker is that
racist keep saying it might turn into
what some racist Australians used to
call my sister because my last name is Q
and they used to color Kunta Kinte
oh it's funny that's not good it's
another shirt guys Kunta Kinte - Kinte
and then make kalila look like blackface
me blackface kalila yeah Kunta Kinte no
they're about very toned
anyway whatever at times we're done
that's finish it do you have any final
thoughts I don't know I'd like to I I
don't touch my feet what happened is it
wet I want to say I want to say
something to BA what is happening I want
to say something to my partner of six
years I want to say a my love to say it
are you gonna be listening what is it I
want to say that we've been through a
lot the last couple months you've been
through a lot the last couple months but
I'm happy to see that you're slowly
coming out of the thick gray cloud and
I'm glad to have you back oh yeah that's
bad no that was not bad Oh baby you got
it no babe you got it you got it get the
legs
I don't know much about anything thank
you
what else good goodnight everyone thank
you for listening to our podcast